what a pleasure theo thank you for
answering the call
this is uh eric in orange beach what's
up eric orange beach man and that's a
we used to go over there and uh for uh
spring break when i was in high school
and there's one kid named billy and he's
i don't know if he has an alcohol
problem but i don't i don't know if he
doesn't
but he uh broke out a window one time
in our hotel room or motel room and then
i think he went to jail or something we
sold all of his clothes uh while he was
in jail
we sold everything out of his luggage on
the strip onward
down here just hanging out tried to
micro dose on the
on the mushrooms and i think i overdosed
but anyway hell yeah bro dude that's my
thing if i'm micro dosing
i'm more crow doesn't son one drop for
me
one drop for me next thing you
next thing you know i'm nine drops deep
i'm 70 drops deep
you're like damn bruh you supposed to be
micro dosing
you got all your clothes off man what
the [ __ ] is going on
it's two in the afternoon
next thing you need my buddy had a pair
of needle nose
helping me pull a tooth i had a problem
with but
never mind that just want to let you
know
uh back spinning the back episodes
hopefully don't run out but uh really
enjoying what you're doing
all right then see you there gang gang
brother
look man if you pulling out a tooth on
shrooms i think that's what i gathered
there then
you doing good work baby anybody that
could bust up bust around in their own
enamel i wasn't that brave
you know you that's you like a baby
kevorkian out there if you're thinking
about
if you're willing to pull one of your
body parts out of your body
when you high on shrooms buddy
that's what i'm talking about that's
dentist the menace bro you the one right
now
dude that's the thing and that's a new
deal you could do [ __ ] dental work on
people that's all gacked out of their
brains or whatever
do open up that 2 a.m
that emergency clinic people just [ __ ]
up
they pop in you do whatever take out an
appendix
you know what i'm saying take an ear off
van gogh somebody
because if you the guy may you the guy
because that's brave to pull your own
tooth out
when you're high on mushrooms man damn i
hope you kept it i bet you gave it to
somebody
now the smoke the smooth move is giving
it somebody you're in love with
you know what i'm saying drop that
incisor in into a girl's palm
make her feel something special because
anybody could
throw you know throw put a wiener in a
lady
but to find a lady and hit her with that
[ __ ] molar baby
one of those strong white mouth dicks
that's a real man good evening good
afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one